[Música]
boa tarde a todos
primeiro quero agradecer ao convite é do
arapuan da unisuam é é extremamente
importante porque começando aqui aparece
o que falar sobre isso a gente só
consegue mudar um país melhor o nosso
país com educação sem base de tudo
a gente vê uma melhor educação a gente
vai ter sim melhores profissionais um
país melhor em relações
vou começar a falar um pouco da minha
vida da minha carreira voltei um pouco
mais de 20 anos de mercado financeiro
comecei a trabalhar muito cedo eu sou
daqui de perto nasci aqui na penha já
mora há sete anos em são paulo mas nasci
aqui na penha
trabalhei bastante também bastante muita
dificuldade teve que ajudar em casa tive
que trabalhar muito cedo em relação a
isso eu vejo muito isso o jovem gosta
muito para estar com os jovens têm 42
anos foi de 43 só de mercado financeiro
tem 20 anos mas o jovem hoje quando ele
vai conversar com eles sempre ansioso
também é sempre queria atingir mais
rapidamente o sucesso tudo isso tudo me
pergunta celson como eu faço para chegar
lá que eu preciso em relação à carreira
como é que eu desenvolvo e aí começa a
conversar com o jovem ele entra na
empresa no dia seguinte ele quer ser
presidente da empresa nisso a lei
highlights ele não sabe nada profundo
mas ele quer ser um presidente que seja
o primeiro
como é que faz para chegar lá e primeira
coisa que lhe pergunta e não para aí
você está num processo uma curva de
aprendizado ou em algum determinado
momento do tempo a minha experiência meu
aprendizado vai funcionar para se for o
caso haverá diretor pra eu pra casa
atingir a presidência mas não no
primeiro momento então jovem hoje recebe
muito mais informação do que eu recebi
é óbvio eu lembro quando entrei no
mercado financeiro caiu de paraquedas no
mercado financeiro foi o que eu falei
que estudar muito trabalhar a ajudar em
casa é já era um profissional já estava
sendo efetivado logo comecei a trabalhar
na comecei a estudar na uff universidade
federal minha mãe dava um colégio
particular então eu conseguir bolsa de
estudos de graça e logo novo comecei a
trabalhar no primeiro período foi
efetivado em uma empresa de navegação
mas eu era muito inquieto como é que eu
faço pra atingir
meus objetivos eu morava não querer o
presidente da empresa mas eu olhava
naquela empresa de navegação por aí como
é que eu desenvolvo aqui eu tenho que
aprender mas onde eu quero chegar e
sempre que eu programei cinco dez anos o
futuro sempre deu errado sempre
diferente
então eu sempre falo isso primeiro
programa em 12 anos que você consegue
chegamos assim nortear sua vida da
melhor maneira possível frustrações vão
existir aos montes você precisa saber
lidar com elas e eu caí de paraquedas
mercado financeiro porque eu era
inquieto que iria mudar já era
funcionário da empresa no primeiro
período de faculdade e ser efetivado que
eu fiz naquela época a consultoria
auditoria foi prestar exame pra kpmg
para r shine são os big five sabe que eu
fiz auditoria fx administração e aí
nesse processo eu fui a entrevista com
sócios num processo de meses dinâmica
provas matemáticas e tecnológico
entrevistas tudo mais e eu cheguei na
entrevista consórcio nas duas ktm gn
é a primeira pergunta do dos sócios da
kpmg não esqueço nunca mais vou esquecer
isso óbvio de uma frustração que a gente
sempre lembra é óbvio as vitórias de
comemora mas passa as frustrações gente
tem que lembrar e serviu de aprendizado
eu primeira pergunta dele agora a
redação você vai ter que falar eu quero
que vocês escrevam uma redação sobre o
que são precatórios inglês
olhei pra ele desenvolvia for você vai
fazer falou assim eu não sei que são
precatórios em português como é que vou
fazer em inglês isso não tem idéia do
que vou escrever aqui
ele melhorou pouco dessa sociedade eu
tenho que ser sincero não vou te enganar
não sei que sim em português isso não
assim foi um baita desafio frustração do
que eu fiz
você desanimou não fala assim porque eu
errei
onde foi que eu falei ali que eu não
passei naquela prova
no ano seguinte fui lá de novo tentar de
novo kpmg n
cheguei na entrevista dos dois até o
final não passei a me desanimar não foi
porque eu fiz de errado
mas aí que fez a kpmg me indicou para o
banco icatú e à energia indicou para a
copa
nas duas eu cheguei fui fazer entrevista
chega na fase final nas duas
aí era ir para a área de mídia na
coca-cola ou ir para a auditoria interna
do bom que captura o estagiário nas duas
né
optei na época não sabia que era o
mercado financeiro foi estudar e acabei
entrando em um banco de investimentos no
dia 16 de janeiro de 1998 eu falei agora
pouco das dificuldades que o jovem quer
aprender as coisas rápido que ser logo
presidente eu não pensei isso o banco
ofereceu preciso ajudar muito o preço
está muito porque do meu lado os
concorrentes morar fora estudaram fora
eu não tenho esse inglês deles eu não
estudei dessa maneira eu estou estudando
na universidade federal que se
desenvolver porque não dá mercado
financeiro nem sabe o que é mercado
financeiro como eu consigo melhorar em
relação a isso como eu consigo entregar
o resultado melhor
a primeira semana primeiro dia me deram
um livro pra quem conhece o mercado
financeiro falou sobre isso até no nome
às redes sociais
eduardo fortuna leia leia ele sexta
feira você faz um resumo sobre esse
livro que fala sobre várias moedas sobre
o sistema financeiro tudo isso
hoje você não tem isso ainda bem imagina
ter que ler um livro resume esse livro
primeiro a perda de tempo
os meus coordenadores em resumo eles
sabiam do início ao fim
segundo pra que eu fazer aquilo é muito
melhor hoje e capturar as informações e
fala resume sobre isso vai fazer um
estudo de caso vai me traz alguma coisa
diferente fora da caixa
é muito melhor então primeiro a
informação eu tô falando de 20 anos
atrás nem farei 16 de janeiro de 98
a informação é muito rápido
o grande ponto é que a gente utiliza
essa informação nosso favor
principalmente os mais jovens
tenho dois filhos um casal de gêmeos
como faz oito anos quem sabe vocês têm
ideia que saiu agora há pouco uma
pesquisa sobre o futuro do trabalho no
mundo uma pesquisa onde tudo lá fora
pelo future shop survey que 36 por cento
da demanda por mão de obra em 2020 é por
resolução de problemas complexos em
segundo não adianta mais ser nerd tem
que saber se relacionar habilidades
sociais
então meus filhos desde os seis anos de
idade eles estudam programação para
abrir a cabeça estudou música e eles
amam a matéria que mais gosta
sexta feira eu quero viajar sexta-feira
de 4 e 5 e 6
eu quero ver a sexta feira um pouco mais
cedo não posso porque eles querem fazer
a aula de programação
então hoje com essa evolução com a
rapidez que os jovens cada vez mais
precisam é tratar esses dados que chegam
e transformá lo então análise de dados é
cada vez mais relevante tem muito mais
informação como é que a gente utiliza
essa informação da melhor maneira
possível em relação às nossas carreiras
esse prato do fundo mercado financeiro
naquela zona a ser extremamente
meritocrático jovens entrarem como
estagiários em 56 anos sócios relevantes
diretores não têm um plano de carreira
você precisa assim se desenvolver e
entregar o máximo possível o retorno
possível no menor tempo possível então o
jovem precisa cada vez mais analisar
esses dados para poder entregar assim um
resultado cada vez melhor e isso eu falo
isso é que eu sou o mercado financeiro
acabou me forjando diria a palavra é
passo isso pros meus filhos eu sou pelo
mercado financeiro meritocrático crítico
e chato nessa hora eu sou chato crítico
e meritocrático mais chato crítico
meritocrático e eu ensino para os meus
filhos a educação financeira o tempo
inteiro é da minha base e na educação
financeira para ele que falou da
importância tudo isso e meus filhos
recebem o gosto sempre de citar isso
quando o modelo de colégio em são paulo
eu fui falar com um ano eu vou mostrar
pra eles
a importância é perguntar também a
importância do colégio estava no colégio
que podia fazer tudo meu filho estava
num puxão de orelha modelo de colégio
com o colégio jogamos assim com um pouco
mais dinheiro arquias que precisava ele
podia fazer tudo então não queria quando
mulheres de seu novo colégio eles tinham
14 anos eu fui perguntar se tinha 13
disciplinas no colégio direito
constitucional básico empreendedorismo e
educação financeira
a diretora falou assim seus filhos têm
quatro anos porque você quer essas três
disciplinas
acho que quebrei ao direito condicional
base por jovens sabem muito dos direitos
das canções dos seus deveres
empreendedorismo porque apesar da taxa
de juros extremamente elevado no brasil
há dificuldades em captar e formar
jovens mão de obra qualificada o
brasileiro é um empreendedor na
a gente tem a criatividade maluca como a
gente fala o brasileiro está toda a nasa
é porque não acredito em atividade
absurda e educação financeira porque
precisa saber lidar com o dinheiro
o brasil o fato de que fica rico é feio
errado a gente tem que mudar um pouco
isso parece mais importa gera mais
emprego e faz a economia girar
e eu falei pra ela olha você tá falando
questão financeira mas meus filhos com
cinco anos 2014 é capaz de fazer 4 com
cinco anos vão saber o que a inflação na
hora
a diretora rio né minha cara ou inflação
céus com cinco anos é um lugar muito por
causa do tempo como eu fui explicar que
a inflação para os meus filhos
todo sábado tinha que levá la a
encontrar um picolé de limão todo sábado
independente estivesse onde estivesse
gravando a padaria para chapecó de novo
e eu fui explicar acabei entrando
economia oferta e demanda filho se
chover muito vai ter menos limão - limão
olha pra fazer um suco que acontece o
preço sobe entender o que você tem que
proteger o seu dinheiro em relação à i
bom os filhos entenderam ainda bem
eles recebem toda semana não é pesado é
semanadas toda sexta feira e lembra a
história eu falei que eu sou
meritocrático que chato mas nessa hora
eu sou mais chato crítica e
meritocrático eu chamo de 22 sofia vê um
carro sexta feira dia da semana nada e
muitas vezes 05 10 reais
e aí quando falo sobre isso na palestra
ou se choca que você faz às vezes não
recebe outro não aparece o soró que
absurdo foi o mundo nunca me deu nada de
graça um recebe o outro não duvidamos
compor 30 sofia se comportou pese as e
muitas vezes quando vou entregar o
dinheiro e fala não pai não me dá o
dinheiro não aplicar o dinheiro que é
muito melhor
qual foi o problema eu criei dos
monstrinhos que começar a falar
meu pai vai triplicar seu patrimônio um
ano falou não faça isso meu filho não
pensem assim estão rindo é verdade e
eles começaram a falar principais amigos
meus filhos que eu vou triplicar o
dinheiro deles um ano cria um problema
enorme
eu falo não existe estabilidade futura
não posso falar a passar mas no futuro
não posso prometer isso não fazem isso
lá em casa não tem cofre porque eles vão
juntar dinheiro e nem a palavra chamar
poupança um palavrão
caso ele não sabe e aí tem uma história
verídica dentre várias principalmente
com meu filho é justamente questionador
e chato como eu que ele falou 'pai eu
quero trocar a minha bicicleta para o
filho não tem data comemorativa
mas eu tenho dinheiro aplicado ok que
vai fazer quero usar o dinheiro para
comprar uma bicicleta nova taxa é usada
que vai fazer voltou a projeção de
caridade foi fechado
estou com você vamos trocar a bicicleta
troquei o colégio dos meus filhos
ainda bem aquilo que eu falei da
hierarquia tudo mais se perder o crachá
eu recebo um boleto de 22 reais para
pagar beleza na mesma semana o filho com
isso conseguiu a proeza de perder ou o
crachá duas vezes
quarenta e quatro reais tudo está me
levando 44 reais em setembro completa-se
cleto o dinheiro acabou da aplicação
financeira dele não tem problema ele
quis usar pra isso deu a bicicleta usada
para uma instituição de caridade ótimo
beleza filhos e me deve r$44 vai usar a
aplicação na aplicação se rege por cabo
pai
com isso você conhece a fada do dente
que não estejam assistindo mas pensei
nem eu vou lá põe o dinheiro r$20
debaixo do travesseiro dele quando ele
perde um dente
ele está achando que a fala doente vai
me pagar foi conhecido então pai quando
eu perguntei a gente ela tem 20 reais
debaixo do meu travesseiro eu te devendo
dois dentes não filho dois dentes 40
reais
você tá me devendo três dentes filho mas
pai ainda 60 reais é esse que o banco
faz com você meu filho pai não quero
isso não mais podia ver um pai a
diferença está aí a diferença grande
r$16 então o que faz com você poupa
então é muito difícil pedir emprestado é
só começa assim como empreendedor
dificuldades que vai ter de trabalhar
também não gostei pai mas você tá me
devendo um dinheiro em relação a isso
a outra história foi voltando de viagem
há pouco tempo e eu expliquei também
custo benefício
olha filho às vezes vale a pena comprar
um produto em relação ao que eu estava
comprando um produto similar mais caro
que o outro e aí falou pai
esse produto é mais barato é igual não
filho esse produto um pouco mais do que
o outro e fico pensando eu fui lá vai me
pergunta pior mais difícil estava
viajando para fora voltamos possamos
brasil será no free shop possamos no
brasil isso foi à noite ele me perguntou
e volta de meio dia uma da tarde coisa
que o valha
pousamos no brasil tal em são paulo a
ele pai quanto é que custa para cortar o
meu cabelo foi nossa senhora que vai ver
eu não sei se a gente faz um combo
quarto eu você e sua irmã das cem reais
tá bom dia seguinte receba foto george
hotz up da minha esposa
olha o que dodô fez com o cabelo dele
não tinha bilhete é cortada em cima não
sei como é que deixar isso no colégio
tudo por que você fez isso vai me dar
meus 35 reais que eu já cortei meu
cabelo muito semelhante o barbeiro falei
filho sem entendeu só parte do custo que
você vai economizar e ficar com 35 mas o
benefício vai ter que aceitar o pai
deixa assim não tem problema para ter
namorada pra lá eu junto mais dinheiro
depois quando tiver na frente e corta o
cabelo eu falamos tudo isso não só é
óbvio que ele tem que tem que viver
frustrações
aí eu posso não vou passar do tempo vai
acabar eles têm que viver com essa
página como comecei a parte
principalmente os desafios que a gente
vive não só profissionais mas a vida eu
faço questão de lembrar todas as minhas
frustrações
a dificuldade em comprar um carro cara
quase na minha idade é o carro porque o
carro tem umas 100 75 anos no carro era
de 78 meu primeiro carro
bebia mais do que eu é obviamente então
assim em todas as frustrações que eu
tive durante a minha vida os desafios e
o que é mais importante
eu acho é a gente saber se levantar
porque a gente só reclama e um de dez
pessoas que se lamentam contratar alguém
isso é várias vezes acontece
eu lembro é contratar um profissional
extremamente bom muito bom muito fora da
curva muito outline muito e ele
trabalhava em uma empresa multinacional
ele só não larga o trabalho todo mundo
na área durou ele foi o cara entra aqui
onde quiser e bom ele tem foco
determinação vontade e tem sido costume
ou pra isso aí conversando com ele
meu sonho é trabalhar no mercado
financeiro e saída da multinacional ir
pro mercado financeiro
a step 15 anos seis anos coisa que o
valha e eu falei com a europa fechada
fechado
dias depois ele não vou mais porque e aí
ele me falou o seguinte olha conversei
com meus pais e eles me falaram que eu
tenho que seguir uma carreira maior na
empresa que eu toco que a multinacional
é na época trabalho no xp
a gente não é uma empresa conhecida
então não vale a pena ouvir a senhora
não vem mesmo não você pode ver que só
para conversar com você para bater um
papo sobre isso pode ser a hora legal
pois às vezes a gente ouve conselhos
tudo mais mas a gente tem que ouvir
nosso coração
só quem sabe e quem percorre a
trajetória somos nós
ninguém pergunta pela gente óbvio que os
nossos pais têm receios que a gente
sofra que a gente se machuque que a
gente erre
mas os erros são nossos as frustrações
são nossas e aí que faz com que a gente
cresça para que a gente levante sempre
iludir
você falou pra mim como foi aqui que seu
sonho no mercado financeiro você é novo
tinha 20 e poucos anos ele na época
falei você pode errar aproveite o
momento para errar e sempre o que mais
me motivou na vida foram os desafios as
decisões
eu nunca deixei de tomar uma decisão
começando com o profissional for assim
eu tenho uma dificuldade enorme
eu tenho três propostas de emprego face
à dificuldade enorme
se a solução não tem três propostas de
emprego melhor do mundo não é muito se
tivesse só uma ou seja pessoas sempre
reclamam sempre se lamentam ao invés de
pegar arregaçar as mangas ea gente só
melhora um país se a gente sim não ficou
no retrovisor e daqui em diante o que a
gente pode fazer como é que a gente pode
melhorar sempre será através da educação
aprendi isso quer dizer suas
experiências com isso a educação é
primordial para isso pretende mudar um
país
a gente já passou por diversas infrações
de perto já continuar daqui em diante
mas eu não fico olhando o retrovisor não
ficar se lamentando e sim como é que eu
posso fazer isso melhor
eu tenho tobi passar isso através de
educação financeira e também é pros meus
filhos
porque aí tentando formar los da melhor
maneira possível já foi avisado que eu
não vos deixar estourar o tempo que toca
uma serena ensurdecedora então eu vou
encerrar aqui
agora faltando 15 segundos obrigado
obrigado pela paciência audiência de
vocês e educação que a gente consegue
melhorar esse país
um grande abraço obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]